meditation is an extremely powerful tool
for developing focus and concentration
as well as for taking conscious control
over the physiological state to attain
self mastery while you might associate
meditation with self-help and relaxation
the truth is there's a lot more to it
than that it can be seriously badass did
you know that the samurai would
regularly meditate on the concept of
death this allowed them to become
desensitized to the subject such that
they could hurl themselves into battle
with no concern for their own physical
well-being tapping into greater strength
and reflexes with no fear pretty awesome
many people believe that coming to terms
with death this way can help them to
live their best lives now a Steve Jobs
said remembering that I'll be dead soon
as the most important tool I'll ever
encounter to help me make the big
choices in life because almost
everything all external expectations all
pride all fear of embarrassment or
failure these things just fall away in
the face of death leaving only what is
truly important remembering that you're
going to die is the best way I know to
avoid the trap of thinking you have
something to lose you are already naked
there is no reason not to follow your
heart powerful stuff this is an example
of using meditation for a purpose other
than relaxation and mindfulness most of
us have little notion of just how many
types of meditation there are or what
can be done with them meditation can
broadly be broken down into two types
Directive meditation and of
non-directive meditation most of us are
familiar with directive forms of
meditation
these include practices such as focusing
on breathing as in breath awareness
meditation an object as in gazing
meditation the body as in body scan
meditation or a word or mantra as in
Transcendental Meditation
we can also place meditations that aim
to clear the mind or disengage with
thoughts into this category that might
include many forms of mindfulness
meditation using this type of meditation
can help us to rise above anxious
thoughts and thus to develop emotional
resiliency they generally train us to be
more aware of what we're thinking of and
therefore to define our own mental state
and how we wish to respond to the world
around us in that regard mindfulness has
a lot in common with the philosophy of
stoicism it can form to developer
interoception
and our emotional intelligence
which is something I'll be talking about
in future on this channel many people
find that the act of meditation itself
is highly therapeutic by focusing
intently you can quiet activity in
unused brain areas thereby reducing
anxiety this can even lead to the
experience of ego death where you only
experience the present moment and lose
any sense of nagging doubt or insecurity
combined with calm breathing practices
this can be highly rejuvenating this is
an intensely relaxing process that may
represent a form of true relaxation that
we rarely engage in anymore many of us
now relax by shooting zombies and
worrying about work Shaolin warrior
monks believed strongly in the
importance of meditative practices such
as Qigong as a means to counterbalance
the effects of intense training if
you're feeling burned out and exhausted
you might need to consider the use of
recovery strategies such as these some
forms of meditation such as yoga nidra
have even been suggested as ways to
reduce the need for sleep that's
something I'll be talking about more on
this channel in future what this also
does is to develop focus
studies show that directive meditation
can help to develop the anterior
cingulate cortex a part of the brain
associated with sustained attention if
you need to write a long essay then
practicing meditation could help you to
achieve that this type of meditation
also increases IQ and appears to enhance
whole brain connectivity you can find
studies supporting these statements in
the link in the description down below
that will take you to the written
version of this post if this kind of
meditation isn't your thing though don't
worry there are other similar practices
that can likewise develop these
abilities for example consider the use
of mental math simply performing sums in
your head can develop the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex which plays an
important role in the executive control
and surprisingly this practice also
enhances working memory which is our
ability to hold and juggle information
in our minds I in my Bane training video
I talked about blindfold chess and this
can likewise massively develop your
working memory like other forms of
directive meditation this can help you
to improve your ability to choose not to
focus on things you don't want to like
stressful things or to stay task
oriented in the face of distraction
researcher Matthew sculpt and his team
suggest that this could represent
interesting new options for treating
emotional disorders
the discipline to focus on a maths task
in your brain gives you the discipline
you need to avoid stressful thoughts of
course the potential performance
benefits are also clear making this an
interesting area for sports
psychologists potentially this could
also make it easier to attain the
real-life ultra instinct the flow state
seeing as the brain only has enough
energy to utilize around three percent
of neural tissue at any given time or to
attend to roughly a hundred and ten bits
of information per second according to
psychologist Jetson muhuali resource
management becomes important training
focus in this way allows us to dedicate
more and more attention to the task at
hand when necessary without distraction
so to get the benefits of meditation you
don't necessarily need to sit like a
yogi and breathe through your nose you
can just perform math in your head
alternatively you might try alternative
forms of directive meditation such as
the productive meditation suggested by
author Cal Newport Newport suggests a
form of meditation where you commit
yourself to working on a single problem
until you come to a conclusion this
involved inherently less focused
attention owing to the disparate
concepts you'll likely juggle and
solving problems but it has the added
bonus of helping you to practice
real-world skills such as the direction
of your mental faculties towards a
single goal I use a similar strategy
that I call Big Ideas meditation where I
tackle a random idea or challenge for
example that could be musing on the
creation of the universe the nature of
consciousness or what I would do if I
was tasked with writing the next Bond
movie I have got about a hundred issues
of Ironman planned out in my head and it
leads to many other ideas in fact I
credit this type of meditation with many
of my own successful projects such as my
app multi-screen multitasking or even
this channel alternatively you could go
the complete other way and try a form of
non-directive meditation an example is a
comb meditation developed in Norway in
1966 he'll repeat a mantra as in
Transcendental Meditation but you also
combine that with a free mental attitude
the aim is to let your mind wander
naturally from thought to thought
studies show that this type of
meditation activates the imagination
network the default mode network these
are the parts of the brain that we use
when we're absent mindedly daydreaming
and that have been implicated in many
breakthroughs such as Einstein's special
theory of relativity which he discovered
whilst working in a patent office
famously and allowing his mind to wonder
only occur meditation actually shows
Reiter activity in these regions van is
seen at rest it turns out that this
process is not just intended for idea
generation but might also play an
important role in helping us to organize
ideas memories and concepts in the
hippocampus and other brain regions
resulting in greater creativity
goal-oriented behavior and even
efficient brain processes as you can see
then meditation is a powerful tool for
becoming a badass whether you want to
overcome the fear of your own death gain
superhuman focus or crack the secrets of
the universe meditation is one of the
best tools for training and reshaping
your gray matter your brain has the
ability to uncover secrets of the
universe whilst you're sat on the bog
it's just an amazing tool that many of
us just don't take full advantage of
meditation is like a workout for your
brain and I don't understand why more
people aren't doing this essentially
meditation is the intentional inward
direction of attention or lack thereof
it simply means using your focus and
control to flex specific brain areas or
to enter specific brain States and that
makes you better at using them through
brain plasticity you might even enlarge
those areas over time what you achieve
with this is determined only by the
brain regions you choose to work out so
my underlying hypothesis is instead of
focusing only on relaxing the mind and
entering a parasympathetic mindful state
we should combine this with other forms
of meditation being mindful and in the
now is great but it's not a kind of
silver bullet it's not all projective ly
superior to any other brain state not a
few value creativity forwards planning
or even a little bit of motivating you
stress a healthy brain has abilities to
jump between brain states as needed by
the environment we should practice
different forms of meditation and
combine them just as we wouldn't focus
purely on one muscle group in the gym
and I've not even scratched the surface
of some other forms of meditation or
meditative like practices what about
using meditation to enter a lucid dream
state for instance which I'll be talking
about soon or to enhance a visual acuity
there's a whole lot more to it than
simply chanting and closing your eyes so
if you hadn't had the results you're
looking for for meditation just yet you
probably just need to try another type
hope you found this video useful
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and share it around how to
help me out immensely comment down below
let me know if you use meditation and
what forms of meditation love to hear
about any more or lesser known forms of
meditation that you
and if you like the idea of training
both your body and your brain then
you'll probably enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training you can get that from the link
in the description down below it's a
training program for your mind and body
and a very in-depth book that discusses
how everything works and there's a
discount on at the moment whilst a lot
of us are still in lockdown
which includes myself hope you guys are
all staying safe and healthy and thanks
a ton for watching this one and I'll see
you soon thanks stem for watching and
bye for now